all right so I did my review of the
Green Lantern teaser trailer and then at
WonderCon they came out with like this
four minute trailer that everyone wanted
me to talk about so now the second
official theatrical trailers out so
we're gonna talk about all of this stuff
so just like in the Wonder Con trailer
you get the gist I have a news from
Power Rangers gives Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern ring then Hal Jordans inducted
into the Green Lantern Corps where he's
the first human ever to do so and I was
gonna let you save the universe and
whatnot now what I like about this
second trailer and the Wonder crown
footage is that unlike the teaser
trailer these are put together to be
epic the first trailer was put together
to be like some sort of comedy thank
yourself okay there's water in the tap
I don't know whoever put together that
teaser trailer should probably be fired
at least and by fired I mean you know
beaten with a rubber hose and it does
show a little bit of humor but it's cool
humor like when he's training with
Sinestro that ring can make anything
make a Gatling gun a flamethrower what
does he make Oh human and you can hear
the condescending tone right there like
you can hear what he's really thinking
Oh human which I mean I would make a
sword swords are cool preferably though
the Gatling gun for the win and you got
some good voice actors in here too yeah
Geoffrey Rush the rig comes through in
reality its limits are only what you can
imagine Michael Clarke Duncan your enemy
is not gonna play fair there's natural
that Michael Clarke Duncan would play
that character's role whenever you have
a character this like you know as big as
about seven rhinos get John Coffey from
The Green Mile it only makes perfect
sense and we see more of Peter Sarsgaard
aka dr. bighead Hector Hammond we're
gonna catch you well again
I've never which he didn't see much of
him in the WonderCon footage so I'm glad
they showed more of him in this trailer
but the ultimate evil supposedly a big
yellow and black cloud which I know is
supposed to be like parallax which is
like this physical manifestation of fear
and ultimate evil or whatnot
I just don't know how many thing I can
find a cloud although it took out Ivan
ooze from Power Rangers so there is that
and it is capable of destroying entire
civilizations and then after that it's
just a lot of cool looking stuff a lot
of epic music a lot of just Green
Lantern badassery and what I like most
about this trailer as well with the
WonderCon footage is that this guy what
happens now is nowhere in either
trailers it's like after the teaser
trailer they were like oh we don't want
people knowing that Jar Jar Binks is
taking human form now cut him out of
every other trailer so three trailers in
all one shitty trailer to trailer so
Green Lantern's looking like it's gonna
be an awesome movie you know to kind of
show that DC has more than you know
Superman and Batman and that's it I
would definitely say don't write off the
Green Lantern because of the teaser
trailer we'll do our best to forget
about the teaser trailer
I think Warner Brothers will - I say we
give it a shot now so I'll put a link
for the new trailer below go check it
out come back here comment below let me
know what you think and that's another
question what would you make with your
Green Lantern ring anything at all
apparently you can make anything I would
make a nuke I don't know if that'd be
smart but I would or I would manifest
that chick from Fast Five right in front
of me just like yeah awesome that is
great this ring is the best Thank You
Ivan ooze who misuse the power you never
did don't lie to me and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more